it's phone season and it is time to
unbox
the media kit for the oneplus 8t
i'm so excited i love unboxing oneplus
phones and i especially love their media
kits because it's always like a really
fun
experience ultra stops
at nothing the most exciting thing about
this is i don't know what's inside of
here
i haven't seen a media guide i haven't
seen a review kit so you guys are
witnessing
me learning about this device for the
first time
ever
me learning how to open a box for
the first time ever i think it goes like
this
yeah whoa
and here it is the reviewers guide all
of the
information that we need to know is in
here
it's like a children's storybook for the
past seven years
oneplus has focused on delivering the
best smartphone experience possible for
our users
120 hertz fluid display will charge 65
performance quad camera system design
oxygen it was 11.
okay this is the table of contents 128
gigs 256 gigs of storage oh yeah buddy
snapdragon 865 we've got
5g there's a new ultra wide camera
123 degree field of view 120 hertz fluid
m
led corning gorilla glass
let's open it okay this case what the
heck
look how freaking cool this is super
cool i love this
this is called the quantum bumper case
cyborg cyan okay let's get you out of
here let's see what the fuss is all
about
oh my gosh
i cannot be trusted i'm
thinking about a lot of things right now
when you think about it i mean this has
been shipped to me
it's probably been all around the world
it has probably received a few more
bumps than that
but it's still the packaging let's open
this up
[Music]
see what's in here first they do such a
great job with all their packaging and
look at all these stickers they give you
so many little stickers
so cute you know what i'm gonna do
i'm just gonna wear this as a gentle
reminder to myself
[Music]
oh is this color look how pretty
wow what color what's this color called
this is
the lunar silver so smooth
it's also got the built-in screen
protector as well which is very nice
we've got our cable we've got our warp
charge
65 beefy boy or girl
i'm gonna set this up read a little bit
more about the cameras and then we'll go
outside and take some videos and photos
so this has a new 120 hertz fluid
display with a new flexible flowscape
display it's got a qualcomm snapdragon
865 processor 5g up to 128 gigs of ram
and up to 256 gigs of storage this has
the widest ultra wide camera ever
at 123 degrees hi matthew
you wanna sit on my lap you want to
learn together hold on a second i need
to read this to you we gotta we gotta
learn something very quickly we can do
4k
30 and 60 and 1080 at 30 60. we could do
super
slow-mo 720 and 480 1080 at 240. isn't
that exciting
hey listen up be excited
matty we could do 4k 30 and also do 1080
30.
uh it's pretty exciting you know we've
got optical image stabilization the
ultra wide
has a field of view 123 degrees
can you believe that do you want to see
the cases
look check us out this one looks really
cool
very excited about this one look at that
isn't that nice
look at that so are you going to sit
here the whole time
or am i gonna get a little bit of uh
a little bit of space okay that has
answered the question
hey you take a selfie let's take a
selfie okay
let's here we go okay well now i need
you and your
do you want down or like what's going on
all right now that i have some space
i'll take some selfies
it's so crazy coming from a display
that's not 120 hertz and then when you
actually do get to 120 hertz display
it's just the smoothness the quick is so
snappy
[Music]
ultra wide is so wide
my yard looks like a football field i'm
gonna get really close to maddie
and see what he looks like in the wide
angle what's wrong buddy
i think he's having tummy tickles
[Music]
okay let's see if we can turn on
macro let's get a super macro in this
apple watch band
whoa
[Music]
that's so crazy
look at maddie
we are now shooting our first video of a
wild
maddie boy in the wild
hey why do you look so sad everything's
gonna be okay okay so my neighbors are
playing who let the dogs out can you
hear that
can you guys hear that and here's the
wide angle video
he looks a little overexposed there we
go that looks perfect
hey maddie do you want to go to the mall
later
too bad there's a pandemic
i know how much you want to go to the
mall we're now shooting front-facing
video
on the new oneplus 8t this looks really
good i feel like sometimes when i'm
doing front-facing videos
they start like either the exposure
isn't right
but this looks good skin tones look nice
the dog is still looking at me
wondering what i'm doing i mean i'm he
wonders what i'm doing but i also wonder
all day like what is he doing this is 4k
30. here's wide angle of maddie hi buddy
and there's a little zoom in on your
little cute face
and there's a real big zoom in on your
face let's go back to wide
and then we'll do a little selfie
version of myself
hello i guess i guess it's kind of a
selfie although it's the back facing
camera not the selfie camera
are you eating a stick you are
this is gonna be 4k cine 30 21.9
widescreen ultra hd cinema quality
feature film we're out here we have
spotted
we have spotted a wild poodle dijon
chihuahua mix and we know that because
we got his dna test hey maddie
let's talk about it where did you come
from where did where did you come from
where did you go how do you like the
cinema quality what are you eating let's
zoom in and see if we can see it oh it's
a stick
the dog is eating a wild piece of
stick
oh we gotta hop into some slow-mo
[Music]
now we've got some video let's take a
few photos tyler would you
would you mind taking a few photographs
[Music]
oh whoa
did we just pop into like a professional
photo studio
i mean my shirt's wrinkled but wow these
look really good
it seems like it's doing a little
lighting effect around the face
i'm super impressed with these photos
well thank you guys so much for watching
i hope you guys enjoyed this first look
at the new oneplus 8t i'm such a huge
fan of everything that oneplus does and
they really do
make a quality phone so i hope you guys
enjoyed this let me know if you guys
have any other questions
and i will answer those either on
twitter or on instagram or here in the
youtube comments i'll see you next time
bye i love this case like this is so
just look at just take a look one more
look
it's cool
okay you're done looking now